надя савченко піднімається до стіни nike
за польський художник нам альвів її
портрет щось написавши прищі рідкісної
української
їм на цифру 6 відкриттям уралу
петля дверна спить російського засобу
славно савченко стоячи в Україні
народну та руїни you wanna заявляючи вчд у
політика
савченко знову і знову він найкраща ідея
все вона не протестанти президентську
змінити і самі на повного дружини
президента саму структуру України самі
закони про запустити ще були робити для
людей
обороти якої рубці треба стати на голу
на чиї обличчя та крупки труба стати таким
диктатура міккі мауса своїх руках для
того, щоб у тебе чіпати і я так
повернути ці владу народу і зрубати
етап ніж їжа ніконів жити та вологу
народного забрав вигляд але син маєш
савченко точильним президентом порошенка
адже під шапку швидким вони на to to be
cool & win на ура джоуї звання героя
україни популярність сам шинку може
стати він забезпеченою для порошенка в її
офісі висип ос такий вид віри
українського фотографа
вільно інтерпретація картини делакруа
свобода свд народ не чи це якраз
не я це просто немає ціни я не просто
другу лайфу туди дитинча взяла з гіршого
ніж у с на мамі
взяв і таку ж майку штани навчання ти
потрібно буде такого забарвлення берці
які не були савченко від шастазавр з
роллю жанни д'арк питча свого першого
виступав парламент депутат коап або до
патріотичних вшанував своїх колег
і не вони
вугілля дачі поважати
все савченко здати маппет відрахування
моральні стандарти в українські
політики
1 до речі президентом вона ми зможемо ну і
очевидне гарний на світ та all i wanna
не орієнтується в тому, що я
вигадують політичний процес ще
хіба не заяви місяця часто дуже таки
плутоній туманніший і найшвидших заплутається
українську плитку einige виводити її на
прямий і шлях дебні заявлялося савченко
люди підходять danesi своїми скорботами і
прах аніме
з людей жили ціна поліцейський зловили
савченко вбити сару зебра тис а інший
доступні з вуст промови савченко пусте
будинках тис реального обміну по місяцю ними
для цільового хочеш говорити прямо
з сепаратистами ось такий пік хіт
їжу дружини однозначній в Україні всякі
політики всякі pr pr менеджери всякі
складу пущай знаю чорнят ще забула ти
не так само таємниці для добрі люди патчі
знайти віддати йому вірити і починають там
критикувати з стиснутому
я дістану я спеціально тасс путін і до
мене прямо я знаю і вірю видавати з
звучіть як ви знання ще й ведена до
Швидкою її популярність чоловіка змініться
а на знайду світу і віктор мене в
українській політиці США 100 трап лиття